titans of the monsterverse are very
ancient life forms
they are super species that have existed
for millions of years and will probably
live on for millions of years after
humanity is gone
that means that they are biologically
immortal but as we have seen in the
movies and the comics of this universe
they can be killed and will die like any
other life form
in this video we will dive into a
question well asked by fans
and critics alike can nuclear weapons
kill the titan super species
and if so why did monarch the military
or other countries use them during the
events of kotm
and if nukes cannot kill them then why
not
let's get down to this theory the
monster worst irons however are so
different from each other and each
possess a set of unique powers that are
not seen in the other ones
so the question is if a nuclear weapon
would be able to kill
them it has to go on a case-by-case
basis
we have to find out so one thing we all
know for sure is that these titans are
immune or unaffected by gunfire and
smaller weapons
but some of them might be heard by
missiles or tank and artillery fire
but aside from the skull crawlers which
are very small the other titans cannot
be killed by conventional weaponry
there is another thing that is a hard
fact and that is godzilla cannot be
killed or harmed by nuclear weapons
in fact he thrives on such things which
is why he must have thought that modern
humans
were allies after all he was reawakened
by the hiroshima and nagasaki bombings
and all those us nuclear explosions in
the sea did nothing but feed him more
energy
in here we will be assessing the tyrants
against tactical and lesser megaton
sized nukes
so here we will discuss 10 of these
titans aside from the g-man himself
and see whether or not they can survive
a nuclear blast
number one rodan also dubbed as titanos
rodan or the fire demon
this incarnation of rodan has a larger
wingspan as compared to any of his
previous incarnations
his physique overall bears strong
resemblance to a bird of prey
rodin possesses an internal volcanic
combustion system causing him
to radiate heat and a temperature of
which can reach up to 1
200 degrees celsius his armor is like
hard and volcanic rock
and seems to be invulnerable to fire
damage but can still be heard by
explosive force
so by that logic the thermal radiation
and the fireball of the nuke
might not be able to kill rodan but its
explosive power could have enough force
to blast him into pieces if he was hit
directly head on
number two mothra mothra's imago form
overall bears resemblance to a gigantic
moth
with four large wings struck behind her
like a butterfly
her main body is stuckier than most
incarnations
so during the movie when rodin's
extremely high body temperature was able
to slowly burn away
and weaken mothra during her fight it
was up to the point that after the end
of the fight
she was reduced to weakly slouching and
crawling form
and then the gravity beams of ghidorah
disintegrated her
so even though she is the queen and has
immortality a nuclear explosion
the fireball which is millions of
degrees in temperature would have
certainly vaporized her
number three calm calm species are
naturally born without armor
so unlike godzilla who has incredibly
thick scales that make him resist
attacks from enemies comb is more
susceptible to injury
as shown when the rotor blades of one of
the helicopters grace his spawn
also suffering severe wounds to his arm
from the helicopter gunfire rounds
and also being half squashed alive by
napalm fire
but we really don't know about 2021 kong
and how durable he is now but going by
what we have now
kong and his species would be easily
killed by a nuke
and even a tactical or a nuclear artery
shell could kill the ape
number four the shinomura nishinomura
was a massive winged insect-like monster
with blue scales
and black membranous wings its body was
long and serpentine
ending in a sharp scorpion-like tail
this titan is literally the only
recorded kill by the us military
by using a nuclear device despite its
affinity for radiation
which serves as its resource for its
regenerative processes
the shinomura seems to lack the capacity
to withstand the blast of a nuclear
warhead
as it was obliterated under such
circumstances
there were two of them actually the
other shinamura was killed by godzilla's
atomic breath
number five the behemoth the behemoth
resembles a prehistoric ground sloth
with large curved dust resembling dose
of a mammoth
knuckle walking in a way reminiscent of
that of a gorilla
in the novelization of godzilla-licking
of the monsters behemoth's fur
essentially
is fireproof as fire cannot burn on it
very little of the heat from the fire
and the military's attacks
affected behemoth's skin which makes it
merely a nuisance for it
this makes behemoth very durable and
also may be one of the few titans that
can actually survive a nuclear weapon
although he might need quite a lot of
time to recuperate later on
number six cilla cilla is a giant
armored cephalopod
she also has a plated shell with ten
tendrils and a pair of black eyes and
six bony legs
it has the ability to abandon its shell
and burrow into a rock phase
or use coupled together parts of sunken
battleships as a replacement
exoskeletal armor until she can grow a
new one to protect
her tender invertebrate muscle tissue
her liquid nitrogen emissions and
extremely hot armor could give her a
very good chance of surviving a nuke
and she could very well abandon the old
shell later on and grow a new one
as it would become scorched after the
explosion
number seven the mutos as a species
demuros are sexually dymorphic
as there are several notable differences
between the males and the females
they are also known as titanus ginsen
mushies the male of these species are
relatively more fragile than the females
and both of them feed on radiation they
can also emit an electromagnetic
pulse that kills everything electrical
within miles and also reduce the power
of godzilla's atomic breath
radiation seems to be their strong point
but then
the military was planning to kill them
both using a megaton size
bomb which might actually kill the most
susceptible
fragile male and gravely wound the
stronger female
getting the nuke to where they are is
the problem
number 8 methuselah methuselah is a
quadruped titan with a forest growing on
his rocky and mountainous back
he has whitish eyes and razor sharp
teeth and also large horns growing down
from the top of his head
that girl inwards his volumes are clawed
while his high limbs are
hoofed methuselah looks to be a rocky
armored titan
and because of that the military
couldn't hurt him so by assessing this
even though a nuke might do him a lot of
damage his stuff armor
would protect him and he might survive
but that mountain on his back would be
gone with a win
number nine the muto prime the ancient
japanese gave her the name
jinshin mushi or the earthquake beetle
due to her ability to create earthquakes
and her beetle-like appearance
monarch names her the mutual prime due
to her being larger and more powerful
than the regular murals
unlike the other murals the murder prime
has a hardened tank-like outer shell
with sharp spires on her back she was
actually able to survive a nuclear pulse
by godzilla
and was only killed by being stumped on
her head by the g-man
this shows that a nuclear weapon could
very well not kill the titan
number 10 ghidorah this is what we have
been waiting for
can nukes kill ghidorah in kotm we saw
him unhurt by the oxygen destroyer
weapon
but let us reiterate that the oxygen
destroy was not a nuclear weapon
its mode of attack is to suck out all
the oxygen
as guitar was from space he oxygen
wasn't really a part of his biology
and therefore he wasn't hurt nukes
however are a different story for this
titan
despite ghidorah's immense durability he
could not withstand
the thermonuclear process that godzilla
released in his burning form
which incinerated ghidorah's wings and
also two of his heads in a matter of
seconds
so given how powerful he is only
successive
thermonuclear detonations at point blank
range would be able to kill him
either that or we drop the tsar bomber
the 60 megaton nuke if not then he will
just regenerate
and will survive the smaller nukes and
so with that we come to the end of the
video on whether the monster versus
titans could be killed by nuclear
weapons
do hit that like button for support and
comment your thoughts down below
take care fam oh wait smash that
notification bell for regular updates